la propagation du corona virus créé de
l'incertitude pour les entreprises mais
ottawa a annoncé aujourd'hui on
l'évoquait 10 milliards de dollars en
prêts qui pourront être consentis pour
aider ces entreprises à passer à travers
la crise
une somme qui sera géré par exportation
et développement canada et par la banque
de développement du canada est avec nous
son vice président et économiste en chef
pierre cléroux merci beaucoup d'être là
monsieur cléroux vous avez des prêts qui
seront consentis à peu près 60 mille pme
au canada
est ce que vous sentez déjà qu'il ya de
l'inquiétude ou des demandes qui sont
formulées par les entreprises de
l'inquiétude en général mais déjà des
secteurs qui ont plus de difficulté
compte par exemple des secteurs d'un
secteur de l'environnement des
événements par exemple servir beaucoup
d'événements qui ont été annulés à
travers le canada
donc c'est un secteur qui sent déjà la
crise le secteur qui vont être affectés
qui sont plus nerveux
si tous secteurs du voyage et du
tourisme même si c'est pas déjà commencé
on sent que les gens changent leurs
options voyage et cela n'est pas
toujours sûr secteur milliards de
dollars bon qui seront gérés à la fois
par le décès et la bdc est ce que c'est
une somme qui commandent percevez sauce
ce montant là qui est octroyée par le
fédéral aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
un montant important si on regarde par
exemple montant semblable en 2008
lorsque la dernière crise financière et
que ça nous a permis d'aider onze mille
pme à travers la cades
donc je pense que c'est un montant
important je pense que ça va vraiment
nous aider à aider davantage les pma
passe à travers cette période qui
souhaitent commencer vous aviez aidé à
l'époque onze mille pme
vous avez des fêtes de me concentrer
près à 60 mais ce qu'on comprend c'est
que c'est pas toutes les pme qui vont
aller cogner à votre porte et qui ont
besoin d'un dense comme un non c'est pas
tout les pme parce que l'impact moins
différent d'un secteur à l'autre et
aussi des entreprises sont en meilleure
position financière que d'autres ils
seront capables des plus patients que
d'eau donc notre mandat nous c'est
d'aider des entreprises qui ont des
besoins
à passer à travers les prochains mois
qui vont difficilement commande ici pour
plusieurs entreprises
donc c'est ça notre but on a plusieurs
outils différents outils financiers pour
aider les pays on est dans une situation
particulière comme c'était le cas pour
la crise financière est-ce que vos
critères pour prioriser les dons pour
accorder certains montants ce que tout
se change ou c'est la poursuite des
activités non en fait on est beaucoup
plus flexible et on est beaucoup plus
patient parce que on veut aider les
entreprises à passer à travers ce
remboursement est par contre ceci dit on
est pas toutes les entreprises il faut
que ce soit une entreprise viable
peut-être en difficulté la cause de la
situation présente mais faut démontrer
qu'on est quand même une entreprise via
oui est-ce que quels conseils vous
donnez là ces entreprises qui vous
appelle qui crient à l'aide pour passer
à travers cette crise laisse que vous
avez des conseils à lardenne
oui tout à fait ce que je conseille aux
gens d'abord de regarder ces vos
fournisseurs faut s'assurer que si vous
êtes capables si vous voulez incapable
de continuer d'opérer
vous devez avoir des faunes ça qu'ils
vont vous aider deuxièmement c'est de
bien comprendre la demande comment votre
demande va changer l'impact de la
situation présente vraie différence
le secteur à l'eau donc il faut
comprendre sa clientèle et un conseil
très très important c'est de gérer son
enquête parce que dans une situation
comme ça nous revenus baissent souvent
nos coûts augmentent et on se sent très
coincé dans nos pneus temps 15 à court
terme
donc c'est important de prévoir donc
l'argent qui pourrait être demandée par
ces pme pourraient servir à quoi par
exemple à payer des fournisseurs le
temps qu'on n'a pas de revenu c'est ça
tout à fait c'est de compenser pour la
période de ralentissement
on pense à perdre dans ce match
d'ouverture quand même temporaire
l'économie va reprendre par la suite
mais cette période peut être critique
pour plusieurs entreprises dont le
financement qui ont fourni
c'est pour les aider à passer à travers
est-ce qu'il ya des plans de contingence
par exemple qui sont mis sur pied qu'est
ce qu'on a dans un plan de contingence
pour les entreprises en fait faut à voir
comment on peut continuer d'opel
malgré la situation des besoins de main
d'oeuvre aussi c'est pas toujours
évident tout à fait vous avez raison il
ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont des
représentants des vendeurs
comment ont réagi par rapport à cesc ont
interdit les voyages par exemple ça va
avoir un impact pour des entreprises qui
exportent par exemple et aussi même la
gestion des employés est ce qu'on permet
aux employés de travailler à la maison
dans certaines industries sont plus
faciles que d'autres par exemple la
technologie c'est souvent très mobiles
alors que l'insecte est même fonctionner
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué mais il
faut avoir un plan de contingence pour
incapable de réagir
même avant que la situation est donc il
ya ces 10 milliards aujourd'hui en prêt
on a abaissé la réserve de stabilisation
financière dimanche ça va libérer 300
milliards ya les baisses du taux
d'intérêt par la banque du canada il ya
un plan qui s'en vient la semaine
prochaine est ce que tout ça mis
ensemble à votre avis va permettre
d'atténuer suffisamment les chocs qu'on
appréhende pour le corner virus je pense
que oui je pense que des gouvernements
ont réagi très rapidement cette fois-ci
tant au niveau de la santé déjà qu'au
niveau d'économies et je pense que ça ça
va permettre d'atténuer la crise qu'on
reconnaît dans les prochaines semaines
il ya plusieurs pme et entrepreneurs qui
vous écoutent monsieur que les roues et
qui espère même chose je remercie
beaucoup pour vos explications ce
soir-là camdessus